do you think you could survive the
Hunger Games Jennifer Lawrence did but
the experience left her with some
lasting scars that she's still
recovering from today while stars like
Haley Steinfeld and Emma Roberts almost
played Katniss Everdeen in The Hunger
Games it's tough to imagine anyone other
than Jennifer Lawrence in the role at
this point by the time she debuted in
The Hunger Games Lawrence was perhaps
best known for her starring role in the
gritty Ozark drama Winter's Bone as well
as her turn as a young Mystique in X-Men
first Class since then Lawrence has
added leading Parts in a number of
Marquee films by well-known directors to
her resume including Darren aronofsky's
controversial mother and Adam McKay
similarly divisive don't look up while
her work in these and other films may be
notable Lawrence has proven to be a
somewhat less prolific actor than many
stars of equivalent Fame the reason
Lawrence effectively took a break from
the public Sphere for an extended period
of time following a string of
substantial negative attention much of
that feeling can be traced back to her
rocket to stardom through the Hunger
Game Saga in a filmed conversation with
fellow actor Viola Davis for variety
Lawrence detailed how she felt like she
struggled with her career and her
personal intuition in the wake of the
franchise before revealing how some
self-imposed limitations helped her get
back on track the star revealed that her
relationship with acting was most
impacted at the height of her career
brought on by her lead role in The
Hunger Games she elaborated I couldn't
really be an observer of life because
everybody was observing me and I could
feel my craft suffering I could feel my
antenna for the business side suffering
and I didn't know how to fix it Lawrence
also revealed that she tends to rely on
her intuition to guide her through big
career decisions and the widespread
attention she was getting altered her
intuition to the extent that she began
accepting roles haphazardly what I had
to do was no movies until something
spoke to me that something was the
script for Causeway a dramatic story
about an injured soldier who struggles
to adapt to life back at home in New
Orleans Lawrence told Davis that she
credits that lengthy acting break before
her appearance as Lindsay in Causeway
with helping her get back in touch with
her intuition Again Jennifer Lawrence's
time after the Hunger Games may have
been emotionally taxing but the actress
also faced plenty of physical issues due
to the franchise's strenuous shooting
process in fact the star once revealed
that she suffered from an extended
period of hearing loss after filming
wrapped on 2012's The Hunger Games
Catching Fire she told Vanity Fair I
went deaf in one ear for months but that
wasn't actually physically challenging
it was just ear challenging because I
got all of these ear infections from the
diving and the water and all of that
stuff and then a jet from one of the
Cornucopia scenes punctured my eardrum
Lawrence made a full recovery from her
ear related injuries but that wasn't the
end of her medical issues around the
time of the Los Angeles premiere of
Catching Fire she fell mysteriously ill
I was getting these really bad abdominal
pains for like three weeks and I didn't
I did that thing where I'm like I'm not
gonna go to the doctor and then I
finally like had a day where I was like
no I need to get this looked at the
source and official diagnosis of the
illness was never publicly confirmed but
Lawrence thankfully recovered once again
it's clear that Lawrence's time both
during and after the Hunger Games series
was challenging in multiple regards
whether it be physically or emotionally
thankfully she made it through the worst
of it and is now back to making plenty
of great movies
foreign